hola a todos lo que quiero hacer aquí en
este vídeo y de hecho también en los
siguientes vídeos es hablar de cómo
tomar una derivada parcial de funciones
con valores vectoriales y el tipo de
funciones que tengo en mente son
funciones que tienen una entrada multi
variable digamos en este caso que tengan
dos variables de entrada o podríamos
pensar lo que tiene una entrada
bidimensional verdad y también tiene una
salida multidimensional así que en este
caso lo que voy a lo que voy a escribir
aquí será la función que en la primera
coordenada tenga t cuadrada menos s
cuadrada también en la segunda
coordenada tenga la función st y en la
última tenga t s cuadrada menos s t
cuadrada muy bien entonces como podemos
ver tenemos una entrada de dos
dimensiones y una salida de tres
dimensiones
y la forma de calcular una derivada
parcial de este tipo de funciones es
bastante directa y de hecho si tú te
imaginas cómo hacerlo seguramente le
basta a atinar entonces la derivada
parcial de nuestra función vectorial b
con respecto digamos a la variable t
pues simplemente será derivar componente
a componente con respecto a t verdad
entonces por ejemplo en este caso en la
primera coordenada al derivar t cuadrada
nos da 2 t y ese cuadrada es una
constante cuando estamos derivando al
respecto de t verdad entonces esto se
hace hacer muy bien entonces aquí sólo
queda esto ahora si derivamos esto de
aquí verdad ese es una constante y sólo
nos queda derivar t que es 1 verdad
entonces la constante sale y simplemente
nos queda es ahora vamos a derivar con
respecto a estas dos verdad entonces la
derivada de esta expresión con respecto
a t pues es una verdad por la constante
que es s cuadrada
s veces la derivada de t cuadrada que es
2 t entonces vamos a ponerlo simplemente
así 2 por ese porte entonces todo esto
fue la derivada parcial con respecto a t
y como puedes darte cuenta esto es
bastante directo y la forma en que se
calcula la derivada parcial respecto a s
pues será similar verdad pero donde se
empieza a poner divertido y bastante
genial es cuando interpretamos estas
derivadas y esto en realidad depende de
cómo visualices la función así que lo
que haré en los siguientes vídeos es ver
cómo se visualiza esta función que es en
realidad como una superficie
parametrizado en un espacio
tridimensional por eso es que puse estos
ejes aquí y espero que así se pueda
admirar lo que esta derivada significa